rarement une absolution n'aura autant
semé la controverse Simon Houle a
agressé sexuellement une femme et pris
des photos de ses parties intimes en
2019 à Trois-Rivières alors que la
poursuite demandait 18 mois de prison la
Cour du Québec qui lui fait bénéficier
d'une absolution conditionnelle le juge
éviter qu'un casier judiciaire l'empêche
de voyager et gâchent sa carrière
d'ingénieur on se sent trahi on continue
de nous mettre dans un processus qui est
contradictoire parce que tout est axé
sur les droits des agresseurs la parole
des victimes les conséquences qu'ils ont
vécues sur leur vie c'est pas pris en
considération le juge monsieur polyquin
souligne que l'agression s'est déroulée
somme toute rapidement Simon haut l'a
reconnu avoir agressé une autre victime
dans le passé sans être accusé un signe
de transparence selon le tribunal
le DPCP va porter la décision en appel
le cabinet du ministre de la Justice dit
tout à fait comprendre le désarroi et la
frustration des personnes victimes faut
faire en sorte que les juges que les
procureurs en fait tout tous ceux qui
sont impliqués dans ces dossiers là et
une formation adéquate pour que c'est
jugements-là n'arrivent plus dans
l'avenir la lueur d'espoir que je vois à
travers cette décision extrêmement
choquante c'est cette volonté collective
de mettre en place des tribunaux
spécialisés et je pense que si on avait
besoin de preuves supplémentaires quels
sont nécessaires ben on voit le une
tristement éloquente le jugement va à
l'encontre du mouvement moi aussi et du
rapport du comité d'experts sur
l'accompagnement des victimes selon les
oppositions je suis outrée je suis fâché
je suis déçu c'est pas avec un jugement
comme celui-ci qu'on pour pouvoir
rebâtir la confiance justement envers le
système de justice mais aussi envers les
victimes le signal que ça envoie la
société
comme si si on a un bon emploi si on est
dans la bonne classe sociale on peut
avoir un espèce de de un passe-droit
mais une considération particulière qui
nous permet d'éviter carrément la prison
l'employeur de Simon a mis fin à son
lien d'emploi ce mardi dans un climat
tendu l'homme de 30 ans demeure membre
de l'Ordre des ingénieurs du Québec ici
Geneviève Garon Radio-Canada Montréal